I think there are a lot of reasons why
there are some people and I don't
consider it to be some major epidemic
sweeping the land but yes there are some
people who resist the insights of
science and I think a lot of this has to
do with how we teach science to young
kids in school right for many people and
I'm talking from experience people have
told me this that science for them in
school they didn't understand it as a
body of investigative knowledge that
gives us insights into how the world
works no for them it was some facts that
they were made to memorize and spit back
on an exam that had no direct relevance
to anything that they could directly see
or touch in some sense it was just
abstract nonsense that they were forced
to memorize and the tragedy of that is
when a young kid realizes that science
reveals the hidden underside of reality
and what it reveals is so exciting when
I talk to kids and tell them about black
holes tell them about the Big Bang
tell them about quantum mechanics and
quantum tunneling how particles can go
through barriers that you wouldn't have
thought possible I can't tell you the
number of times kids will say to me that
science that's cool and science needs to
have that experience for kids where it
just grabs them as the most exciting
dramatic story of discovery and if you
have that experience as a young kid
science is not a subject it's not a test
that you have to take science is your
ticket to understanding the world and
the universe and then it's with you for
life
if you can have that experience it
changes everything